let's talk about net neutrality we've
been doing this every week because this
is the most underreported story in the
mainstream news they are dropping the
ball surprise surprise the FCC flipped
net neutrality net neutrality was
basically the principle that everyone
had equal access to the Internet and the
Internet service providers couldn't
throttle your internet based on the
companies that they are connected with
that is no longer even though Obama said
he was for net neutrality he appointed a
telecom lobbyist who was also a campaign
bundler and the guy flipped net
neutrality you can check that out if you
don't believe me
the Sunlight Foundation published a
series of graphs explaining lobbyist
spending on net neutrality and I think
it pretty much explains the whole damn
thing so giant companies the internet
companies like Verizon AT&T and Comcast
the big boys they basically the red what
you're seeing there these are reports
that they issued through their lobbyists
that we're against net neutrality and
then somehow net neutrality got flipped
and if that's not enough of proof for
you about what's going on here that this
is just about money let's look at the
next one this is the total lobbying
expenditures of the top 20 organizations
with the most reports mentioning that
neutrality and yeah if you're against
net neutrality you spent a [ __ ] load of
money on reports lobbying politicians
and then as we talked about a couple
weeks ago there was a Senate Commission
on net neutrality and literally every
senator on the Commission had taken
money from Comcast and the only one who
fought against it
was Al Franken because he had taken the
least amount of money so if you don't
know what's going on here it's pretty
obvious at this point so I'm gonna keep
talking about net neutrality even though
I feel like the ship has sailed and it's
really sad what what should we do for
people that exist in this online space
and it's the last vestige of freedom in
this freaking country slow the the
reports people putting out report after
report like if someone gives me
thousands of reports I hate that I so
why is that working that should not be
working what is it with politicians they
love report I was thinking the same
thing like does that ever get to the
politician himself like they just hand
them a [ __ ] stack of paper yeah oh
this report give me another
yeah sponsored by the bad guy I just
think I think it's like Oh report cool
where's that money again yeah that's so
it's so frustrating it's there should be
the problem what's so frustrating is the
money that they're using to buy this
influence comes from people who are
using their service viewers like you who
are losing who are basically paying to
pay more later that's so frustrating
yeah and I honestly don't know what the
solution is there is no real so I mean
but it works the same way any resource
works where the my you know the people
who have who are controlling how its
doled out and the scarcity of it have
all the control yeah because what are we
gonna do like I mean there's there's no
I can't even have like you know bunny
ears on my antenna anymore and you know
so Time Warner and makes me have a box
inside my house right so literally what
was free the free to get the basic
channels of like ABC Fox and whatever
that was free and then they went digital
so you can't not have just free
television what is public service you
can't even get that any yeah it's it's
it's one of the most frustrating things
because it's such a complicated process
that is unfolding not before our very
eyes somewhere tucked very deep away and
that we can't even get to under it's
like my freaking credit report like I
don't even know how that works but it's
affecting my life you know yeah I mean
it was bad this has been heaven I mean
this type of thing has been going on in
every facet of big business and the
Internet is the biggest you know
channeler of information and commerce
now and it was just a matter of time
where things are regulated by kind of
monopolized by the big guys you know and
you're right we don't understand how
does this thing work I don't know it was
in a series of tubes
we just go back to the simple days of
the AOL running man also speaking of the
simple days are we gonna look back at
this time and I've asked this before
when we've done this but will we look
back at this sort of 2002 just about now
as the as the glory days of the internet
like 10 years from now when it's all
really controlled and throttled and
you're paying per whatever per view or
per data are we gonna look back and go
wow it was pretty good back then it was
pretty good it was evil playing no this
isn't this is the me thank you got it
but it is very yes this is the golden
age right now because right essentially
what we had in terms of you know the way
people the kind of content that people
want to enjoy typically is like video
content right and or at least they want
to read it on your own but if you
compare it to the way cable used to
cable works is there's tiers of cable so
if you want to watch all that but that
whole model of cable is disappearing and
so the telecom still want a tiered
system so they can charge you for more
and what's happening now is our ability
to get around all of that all these
people who are like listen I just want
to sign up for Hulu and Netflix and have
it on my watch
are totally winning they pay so much
less every month and right now the
telecoms are realizing that and they
want to still have that model and
they're trying to you know get it that
way and they have all this money from
the old system and they're just gonna go
for it yeah and if you don't think the
old system and the telecoms are screwed
up there was just a report issued this
week about how our internet in America
is like one of the worst for
industrialized nations so we're not even
getting good service in the first place
but I guess we don't even know it cuz
when was the last time you guys were in
Korea South Korea to check out North
Korea the other day
you